Snoop Diggity Doo Dog as you know said
that he was going to give up smoke but
it turns out Snoop had another trick up
his sleeve here it is I have an
announcement I'm giving up
smoke I know what you thinking Snoop
smoke is kind of your whole thing but
I'm done with it done with the coffin
and my clothes smelling all sticky icky
I'm going
smokeless solo sto fixed fire they took
out the
smoke
clever
Snoop is there obviously High toasting a
marshmallow it's clever I love even the
commentary of the ad where he just looks
at you and you it's so officiously lame
that it's actually cool and funny again
goes clever I'm going smokeless for this
fire pit that I have outside that dirty
dog he got us again